thank you sally for awesome introduction
and i'm glad to hear
glad to be here with you all and it's
awesome that we can meet
i mean it's the pandemic like this uh
and without further ado let's jump into
the topic
i personally am very passionate about
this topic and i had the
fortune of implementing some projects
uh using mlaps as it was developing
throughout
these years just let me know if you are
able to see the screen and then we get
started
yes sounds good awesome
so glad to be here once again
just so i introduced myself i just made
a slide
uh of who i am uh so basically
uh as most of us uh are from helsinki i
also
i'm based in helsinki i work at theater
every as a senior machine learning
engineer
and i have six years experience in ai
and machine learning
and i've worked in companies like silo
ai
uh bank it on and some startups in my
previous experience and also
i have graduated from arkada university
for applied sciences
as part of the master of engineering big
data analytics and
apart from my ai and machine learning i
try to keep it fun
i enjoy traveling meeting people and
playing cricket as i come from india
originally
so cricket is a special sport and
i've been fortunate to work with ml ops
as it was developing especially
and it was booming in the last two years
so i decided
to write a book about it especially
because
mlaps is dynamically developing and
there are a lot of scattered information
on the web
and it is hard to wrap up our head
sometimes with all this information so i
took this opportunity
to compile this book and it's coming out
very soon
so today i'll be presenting some of my
learnings that i've had
working with mlaps throughout the years
and also one of my hobbies
is to keep myself acquainted with
research and participate in
it actively and especially in the topics
of edge and cloud computing
mlaps natural language processing and
computer vision so if you're
into research as well please feel free
to share
awesome ideas that we might be working
on
so before we jump into mlaps
i think there are different kind of
people here in the meetup
some come from business background some
from mostly from data scientists and
machine learning engineers as well uh so
just to take it a bit easy let's look at
how
ai is changing the world uh right now
it's 2021 and already we can see the
transformation happening
and it is anticipated from these sources
like gartner pwc why are new york times
that by 2022
there will be 75 million jobs lost
because
we see automation is all around us
especially with the pandemic
and there'll be 133 new million
million new jobs created during this
time so there's a
big transformation going on and as a
result of this
economies also are changing and there
will be a huge economy growth of
13 to 15 trillion anticipated by 2030 so
this is all exciting times to be part of
this transformation
it's a great opportunity uh to learn
evolve and thrive um and
i i guess many of us have heard about
andrew ng who is a famous
influencer in the ai world and in 2016
when
i was kind of new to ai and
finding my way through building machine
learning solutions in the market
i came across this quote by andrew ng
which says that
ai is the new electricity and it caught
my attention
and when we look at how electricity came
into this world when electricity was
invented
it still had to reach to all the homes
and all the devices
that we have today so in order to do
that we've developed a mechanism
to mass produce electricity through
factories
and in the same way we are right now
with ai as well
and ai is the new electricity as android
ng says and we need a
mechanism to mass produce ai and
ship it out to companies homes and
all around the world to actually see the
full potential of ai come to light
so i believe this factory here
is evolving to be mlops and today we'll
look at this ml ops
and mlops is in simple terms uh software
engineering approach which enables
organizations and ai developers to
collaborate
in order to automate
machine learning operations so we'll
look into it
and before we go into mlaps we'll look
at the problem
that's there at hand and what mlops is
solving right now
so as we can see multiple sources have
stated like gardner and venturebeat
60 of data science projects have failed
in 2016
and and it kept on increasing because
there was a lot of hype from 2016
around ai and many companies many people
were trying to
build cool stuff out of ai but many
failed
uh and also in 2019 87 percent of data
science and
ml efforts are failing and they never
get to impact
businesses and when we look at it look
at it why is it so
uh there's a famous influencer called
terry singh
and he analyzed the market trends and
he came up with these three factors that
are uh quite
relevant in the market because of which
the ai projects are failing
so if you look at it
companies are not able to apply ai and
generate business value
for various reasons it can be cultural
it can be
the way they operate it can be many
other factors
and also there's a lot of hype still in
the market
and thirdly and most importantly i think
this is where
the key is to unlock the full potential
of ai
it is to um to enable continuous
learning and
because of lack of continuous learning
you are not able to realize the full
potential
ai has to offer to realize the business
value
that it can offer so
just that we are getting into mlaps now
we'll just look at how
ai in research is different from
production
just to understand from two different
lenses
of how things can be because it's very
different in research and it's very
different in industry when it's supplied
to solve
business problems so when it comes to
these parameters such as
performance priority data fairness
interpretability complexity and the
other parts
the focus in research is to always
challenge the state of the art
but in production it is we need models
which are
better than simple models which are able
to efficiently do
tasks and generate business value and
when it comes to
training the focus in research is fast
training and
production it is fast inference and when
we look at the nature of data
in research there's usually static data
sets
that researchers work around to develop
models but
in production the data is constantly
changing
so it's very different in this case and
yeah all of the rest of factors as we
can see
um how production is different from
research
especially fairness and interpretability
it is good to have them
in research and not so important in
production in many cases but these days
it is important because we can see a lot
of uh debate going around the way ai is
making decisions in our everyday life so
hence it is important in production
and everything else in
production seems to be a bit different
from how things are done in research so
the way also software development has
been shaping up
um it's pretty interesting actually we
started from the waterfall model
where we it was unilateral where we
developed
software in one direction without much
iterations and it was how we started to
develop software
the internet came and then we moved to
the agile methodology where we
developed software and iterations and
sprints
uh with with interaction with the user
taking the feedback so there was some
development
and then we went on to the devops which
is quite popular
for enabling an id mindset of
collaboration communication
integration and automation and it has
stages like build test and deploy if
you're a software engineer you
must be familiar with that so this is
how software has been changing and we'll
look at some other trends
which are leading to envelopes to
understand how it is making an impact
and also just not to go much into detail
because of bravity of time
uh the point of this slide is
computation
um is improving every year and because
of that
you're able to produce state-of-the-art
deep learning algorithms like alphago
or even gpd3 and these sort of
algorithms
and a computation is improving by 35
times every 18 months that is the rate
at which we are
improving the computation but of course
we will hit a roadblock
and it can't keep on going like this and
we are moving to new trends
where we are seeing distributed uh
computing
where the computation is distributed
across multiple nodes
so how do we cope with this sort of
changing
computational behavior and also how do
we deal with
the nature of data the big data the
volume
of data it's huge these days the
velocity at which it is being
uh generated uh the veracity and the
variety in terms of structural and
unstructural data and of different
formats
image audio and different formats in
which the data
resides and is generated so how do we
deal with all of this mess
and we simply cannot do it by the old
ways of doing
of course the world is changing we also
need to evolve and
thanks to machine learning operations
this ml ops method that we have
developed
the ai world has developed to
to deal with all of these trends of
dealing with infrastructure
dealing with the changing trends in data
and also
dealing with the nature in which the
software is developed so in a nutshell
mlaps is the devops of machine learning
and it's a hybrid of devops of course
which takes into consideration
the data code and machine learning
models to generate
business value and let's see how it is
different from
devops so the way we develop
in devops is we keep uh data and code
separate
usually we don't version data
at least we version the data we have
version control for data
but in that case when we don't version
data
the code that we keep developing
and the data that is constantly changing
in production
is uh dynamically going in different
directions
as the time progresses so we see that's
why the data and code are going
in different directions and it's hard to
maintain both as we go and progress
along the time
and this is where mlops plays a crucial
role
to tie data and code together by
enabling
versioning for data versioning for code
parallelly and tying them both together
to enable
machine learning operations in
production
so the way amalops does
is it uses code it fits to the data to
generate the models and
it it maintains the version of data code
and models
so all of these three are tied up
together and it makes
it makes it easier to develop software
in this manner
and you know in a big picture the skills
that are needed to make
machine learning operations is a
combination of
data engineering where you build data
pipelines to fetch your data
and you need to have devops skills and
also machine learning
skills to build the models so the fusion
of these three
is coming together uh to enable machine
learning operations and
this is how a data science
life cycle goes on these days
where we start by understanding a
business problem
where we get the business understanding
we understand that
value chain we understand the use case
we map out the data
and then we do the data analysis for the
acquired data
we build pipelines and we version
the data and store the artifacts and
this in a nutshell is the
word eye view of a machine learning
operations of how it enables the data
science life cycle
in an efficient way and of course using
this data
we develop machine learning models by
doing
feature engineering uh model training
model evaluation
and packaging and good thing is all of
this is enabled using
continuous integration and continuous
deployment
to deploy these models that we develop
in
in various ways as apis as streaming
services badge service and so forth
so this in a nutshell is the bird eye
view in which
uh mlaps enables uh to get
and give us business value from solving
business problems
using machine learning and
when you when you look at how we
productize machine learning
we need to have keep this in mind i
always keep encouraging people
to look at it this way it's not about
building cool
models and deploying them it is more
about building the
pipeline as the pipeline is the product
not the model
when it comes to productizing uh machine
learning because
the better pipelines the robust the
secure pipelines you have
to operationalize your machine learning
operations the better you're able to
serve your users and
generate business value so
this is a way of thinking
[Music]
and pipeline is a product
and i want to present to you today that
ml ops workflow that
i've developed together with all my
colleagues
and and and mentors of course
throughout these years using this data
science approach
uh data science uh design science method
from
fairinga where we take an artifact
in in my case it was a machine learning
workflow which i will present and
it is a result of multiple iterations to
different problem contexts
and these problem contexts are different
customer projects
are different uh settings to solve
business problems using ain this problem
context can can
consist of software hardware people
organizations
services and many other factors so
as a result of multiple iterations of
this design science method
um i was able to come up with this
machine learning workflow
and there are three modules to it and
because as we see out there there are so
many resources
that we are bombarded with so much of
information from google amazon
uh and many other cloud providers it
gets a bit confusing
so this data this mloff's workflow
uh is developed keeping in mind
uh to keep it very generic that it can
fit to multiple use cases
where we have the build module
where we build the machine learning
models using the machine learning
pipeline and then we deploy the machine
learning models
and the deployed machine learning models
are then monitored
using explainable monitoring method um
so in the build pipeline
we start of course in machine learning
workflow by ingesting the
needed or acquired data to solve a
problem
and after we ingest the data we the
pipeline
trains the model and we we get the train
model and we
evaluate it by testing it with test data
and then
once we have a good results uh the
we approve it then we package the model
in the needed format
in order to deploy it and before we
deploy it we
register it to the model store and this
is the way
in which we are able to build machine uh
build machine learning models in
mlaps and then we can deploy the models
from
model registry
and before deploying you can of course
test the
application and that is the whole
thinking behind the
bob's devops mindset to to
test the deployments before they go into
production so
we can here we can have multiple stages
we can have a dev environment we can
have
qa a quality assurance environment
before we release it to the production
and once it is
released to the production we can
monitor it using
explainable monitoring methods
monitoring again it's a complex topic
and this is where i think a lot can be
done
in order to get the business value um
i have shared uh quite a lot about this
in the
book that i've written and monitoring
component has these three modules uh
monitor module where we can where we can
monitor
different aspects of the inference data
in
data drift uh model drift and
application performance
because the data is dynamically changing
we need to monitor
the ways in which it changes so that
we're able to retrain our models and
keep the models updated
to the changing trends in the data so
that is one way to monitor the
production
models and then we can analyze the
models
and in analysis we can analyze for the
fairness of the model
using techniques like data slicing
uh and also we can look for the bias if
there is a bias in the model in real
time
and also we can look for local and
global explanations
so as you can see monitoring is a very
comprehensive module
and as a result of all of this
monitoring and analysis
we can govern the whole system and as a
result we can automate the whole
pipeline and the whole ml system and
that is the beauty of envelopes
that we can go to complete automation
or we can have as much as control as we
want in the pipeline
and in governing module we can
monitor the errors potential errors set
alerts and actions
to deal with potential errors that might
arise
and take actions based on the results
from the machine learning model
and those actions can be connected to
the real life
application and yeah these are the
the ways in which the machine learning
workflow uh the ml ops workflow will
help us to
automate machine learning operations and
on top of the machine learning workflow
these are the five
different drivers that enable the
machine
learning operations workflow starting
from data
as we can see there's always training
data that we have
uh in the data repository and then
there's testing data where we test the
developed models and then of course
there's monitoring data
as a result of collecting the inference
the input data to the model and also the
predictions that we can analyze later
and take certain actions by governing
the
machine learning system and
code as we can see we have a training
code testing code and
application code and as a result of
using code on data we produce
train models we can package the models
and
we can take these models to production
and middleware plays an important
part in this workflow where we use tools
such as kit
to to version the code
and also we used uh orchestration
container orchestration
uh tools like docker and model registry
which are part of clouds usually cloud
like amazon or
azure and then we use kubernetes
um to orchestrate these container
deployments and
we can secure the application using
virtual nets and different methods
so lastly all of this is enabled by
the infrastructure in form of training
compute
production compute and also the central
storage which stores all the
artifacts the code and data related to
the machine learning
workflow and using all of this we can
enable
the model retraining which is an
important aspect of
continual learning so by enabling
continuous learning
we can bring continuous value of
business value
to our problem context and
i will just discuss with you two use
cases that
in which machine learning ops helped
my customers uh before i go into the
demo part
so that we understand the kind of
business value it is able to generate
so we had a big nordic power company
and they had multiple teams working in
multiple units and
everyone was trying to do machine
learning and it was in a siloed way
and here is where we developed this
machine learning ops
workflow for the company where they were
able to
standardize collaboration for data
scientists and
by enabling such collaboration for data
scientists and providing a
framework we were able to free up 20 to
30 percent of the time
from mundane tasks such as training uh
training models again and again and not
keeping track of them
or or
or licensing with data and also cleaning
data and these sort of
tasks so these ended up saving some
costs
and made the team sufficient
second use cases where nordic hospital
had researchers and these researchers
had uh had had been using
high computation uh resources such as
gpus which were
running 24 7 and it was not needed to
run them 24 7
and using machine learning ops framework
we could enable the
compute provisioning facilities to
to provision the compute whenever it is
needed and this reduced the cost by 70
it enabled the researchers to be more
collaborative and efficient in their
tasks
so these are the ways in which
machine learning operations enables
organizations by making them
efficient and and also
cost effective as well so machine
learning ops is
dynamically uh developing for the last
couple of years and there's a lot to
digest and there's information scattered
all around the
web so i i took this
i personally faced this problem of
having scattered information and i took
the opportunity
to compile all this information in this
book
it's called engineering envelops and
it's a beginner's guide for
data scientists and operational
professionals to rapidly
test build and manage production machine
learning life cycle
so you can find more info about a
machine learning ops in this book which
is coming out soon in march
before we go ahead let's jump into the
practical side of it
the demo part and before we
uh deep dive into the demo
i hope it was all clear so far just give
me a thumbs up if you're able to
hear me because it was all me speaking
all this time yeah it was great
yeah we have a couple of questions in
the chat section
should we address them now or after the
demo
um maybe we can take one or two now
and then after the demo we can take all
right sounds good let's take a couple of
them now
so okay uh first question by stefan he
asked
how did you manage to monitor drift in
particular
yeah so drift uh can be monitored in
three ways
uh one is the data drift the
data drift you can monitor the changing
nature of the data
um of course to do this i've used um
there are multiple tools available of
course it's a matter of your
your personal choice there are tools
like uh
visualization tools which help you look
at the drift in real time
i i can recommend some for example power
bi is one
where you can you can run some uh
some uh jobs to assess the changing
nature of data
so data drift can be measured like that
and then there is something called
feature drift where you can see the
drift in
the way features are changing over time
as well so you get some insight
and the drift can be measured using
statistical methods like min
max and their euclidean distance and
other
other methods that you can use so
there's no one-stop
uh method that can assure you to monitor
drift so every
use case can be different but there's
some standardization to it
and thirdly the model drift is the
changing nature of the model
uh related to the data drift so
um so this can be
monitored by using another model
that takes in the input inference data
compares it to the training data
and statistically shows you how the
model performance has been changing
so these are the three ways in which we
can monitor drift
all right perfect all right let's take
another one
so thomas is asking there is a number of
commercial platforms available today for
handling email ops
what is your opinion about using one of
them versus taking
into use open source tools
yeah uh and i'll just follow up on that
what what
yeah go ahead yeah go ahead this is the
first part of the questions
yeah i think this is a huge problem the
envelopes landscape is
is bursting out with a lot of tools
every day new tools are coming out and
and if you look at the nature of these
tools many of the tools are doing the
same job
and what i would recommend is to wrap
our heads with the principles
and the way we can apply to to make
these principles happen
and i think for enabling mlaps you need
some cloud or some computational archit
uh some infrastructural service provider
which you can rely on so i would
recommend you starting with some
some cloud out there at least to begin
with like amazon or azure
are good to start with and it's it's
interesting how they are
developing their product as well and in
the demo i'll show you some
some bits and pieces of how azure
machine learning service looks like and
how it enables machine learning
operations
so i think it's good to start with one
of the cloud providers and then
expand the same learning to other tools
all right yeah and for example atieto
what have you used
as a tools and what would you recommend
yeah this is the good part about working
at theater i get to work with
multiple tools because multiple
customers you have
multiple customers uh so at least i
i i used uh multiple tools um
starting from azure uh machine learning
service
aws um and then valohi which is also a
finnish company
and what these guys do is pretty
fascinating because they're cloud
agnostic
they i find that pretty cool because
you're not tied to
one cloud so yeah i've got the privilege
of working with multiple
two tool providers uh but there's no one
one-stop solution that we have at
theater we have to be agnostic
because customer needs are changing all
the time
yeah yeah i think even in in the open
source field there is quite
a lot of different tools for example we
have keep flow and ml flow
and everyone it differs on if you have
kubernetes
resources in the company or not or if
it's a large or a small team
so what is your your take on that
yeah so these are some fundamental uh
principles that are machine learning ops
the tools basically need to do
uh versioning of the data without
versioning of the data it is not mlops
so we need to see if we are versioning
the data
versioning the code and then of course
infrastructure can differ from
situation to situation but there is a
mass adoption to orchestrating
deployments using kubernetes so i think
it's it's one thing to learn
how to deploy containers using
kubernetes
on kubernetes driven infrastructure
and otherwise we also need to know how
to
deploy on-prem as well so
at least these basics if you know you'll
be able to be agnostic
to different use cases all right
sounds great all right so let's let's go
for a demo now and after that we can
take
other questions awesome let's do so um
so this is azure um
i'm gonna show you a use case which i
implemented for my book
um so like out there um
there were less resources which took one
use cases and implemented so i took this
chance
to create a hypothetical use case uh
where
i'm um i developed some synthetic data
to replicate a situation of uh
of a location in finland i call it turku
the port of turku
where the business problem is that we
need to develop some
a model that predicts weather four hours
in advance so it's a time series
multivariate time series prediction
problem so this is a machine learning
workspace
which is quite central to machine
learning operations so this is the hub
where we tie up all our machine learning
operations as you can see
that machine learning workspace has the
data sets that we used
tied up together as you can see i
registered all these data sets
the training data set which i will show
you in the meanwhile
uh then the validation data set the raw
data set so you can version your
data and it's all connected to this
workspace and then there are the
experiments
meaning the model training that i run uh
support vector machine
i've trained random forest classifier to
classify if
there's gonna be rain uh four hours
after
a given time or not and you can see the
pipelines
the models that you train everything is
connected to this workspace and
these are all the endpoints that you
deploy as well so i've deployed
two endpoints one is the dev environment
where i test out
the endpoint for its robustness uh and
also there's a prod
uh develop deployment we'll go into the
code as well
just giving you an overview you can
provision
computation resources whatever you want
to train your machine learning models to
deploy them so for example i've
provisioned a kubernetes cluster
and here i've provisioned a virtual
machine to train my machine
learning models and then of course you
can
label the data and do all sorts of stuff
so this is a hub
for implementing machine learning
operations so i will just jump into
this virtual machine to show you some
code of
how azure machine learning at least
enables us to implement machine learning
operations for
any given problem
so you can access your virtual machine
like that and
all of us data scientists are familiar
with jupyter
lab so why not use it so i've
[Music]
like we've seen in the slides here in
the same way i have developed this
these steps the machine learning
pipeline has data ingestion date model
training
model testing model packaging and model
registration
so if you look at the code here this is
the raw data set that for for
for the book purpose i synthetically
generated this data
so you're free to use this data to learn
uh to implement machine learning
operations
for this data for this problem so as you
can see the location is
port of turku because i wanted to make
finland famous
i thought why not have turku in here and
then
different parameters of the weather
conditions like
temperature humidity wind speed
visibility
and the current condition of the weather
meaning that
one means that it is not raining and
zero means it is raining the reason i
put this raining problem is because
sometimes the logistics at the port is
affected
if the ships are importing or exporting
cargoes if it's raining in harsh
conditions then
there are delays at the port and the
logistics get disrupted so
being able to predict weather conditions
at a location
ahead in times uh helps the
administration of
uh the poor to plan logistics um
to carry out uh logistics in a
successful way so that is the business
problem we're dealing with here
so of course the first step is to split
it into training and validation data
sets
so i've split that and then i'm
registering these data sets um
using the azure machine learning
service sdk so there is a python library
which comprises of the sdk functions
so you can use these functions along
with your machine learning code
it's straightforward after splitting the
data sets
i register the data set
to the machine learning workspace after
i make it into a csv so you can see the
data sets
here they're nicely version and
after versioning the data sets i go to
the data injection step
which is this step i ingest the data to
the machine learning pipeline
and do the feature selection and scaling
before training the model and after we
do the feature selection and scaling
um i train the model here support vector
machine
which is quite popular um
did some grid search to determine the
optimal parameters and using those
parameters
train the support vector classifier
model
and after training the model i've
registered it
to the workspace and before registering
it to the workspace
i package the model into open neural
network
exchange format so this format is
getting quite some traction in the
ai world because it enables
interoperability
like let's say sally has developed a
model in tensorflow
and i work in pytorch so
he gives me his tensorflow model i'm
able to de-serialize from onyx format
his tensorflow model and i'm able to
work in pytorch with the same model so
that is the kind of
functionality the onyx serialization
format
enables so after packaging the model in
onyx format i'm registering the model
using the azure machine learning sdk
and i can give some tags i can point to
the data set that i used
in order to connect the data set to the
model that was used to train
so everything is well documented and in
the future if you want to
reproduce the model you can reproduce
with using the same data set
the same uh hyper parameters that were
used to train the model
uh so that's that that is how uh mlobs
can enable such
reproducibility functions and log
everything
together so yeah
basically the models are
saved to the machine learning workspace
and next
um i've used another service called
azure devops
um this is a devops
workspace where we can
we can make machine learning pipelines
so here is the code again
um maybe i will not go much into the
code due to the brevity of
time here but i'll show you one script
where i'm using again the azure machine
learning
sdk um to
infer the model so basically i
deserialize the model the onyx model
from the model store that we saved the
model previously or registered the model
previously
and dc after deserializing it there is
this
function called run function which takes
in the incoming data
from the users and then infers the data
and
predicts using the incoming data and
sends out the
prediction if it has rained or not rain
so that
the port of turku authorities can
determine or plan their logistics so in
order to do this
i've enabled the continuous integration
and deployment
features using the devops pipeline
the release pipeline so you can see
this is the pipeline where i'm
connecting
to the artifacts that we previously
generated
using azure machine learning service so
you can see the support vector
classifier
here the model scalar so before
inferencing we also need to scale the
data incoming data at the same scale
which was which which we used for the
training
uh training of the model so if i make a
change in
my repository it also triggers the
pipeline so this is the
dev environment and this is the prod
environment i'm deploying my
machine learning support vector
classifier to the dev environment
and if it is successful in the dev
i do some load testing as well so
all of these you can you can our
meticulously it's listed in the book on
how to implement
so if you're interested to learn you can
refer to the steps there
due to gravity of time we can't go into
much details but this is the way
production deployments are done
you can see all the logs and you can
after the endpoints are deployed we can
go to the endpoint here and we can
consume the endpoint
and give the users the endpoint
information to make inference
so here you can see the code i can run
the inference
and show you this is a sample code where
i'm taking sample inference data
and pointing to the url there and
performing the inference for each
element in the data so you can see it's
predicting no rain
ahead in the future so the inference
will keep going on
and you can see the application
performance that we have deployed this
application
so we can see the performance of the
application here as you can see
that we are making uh requests and
11 requests are failed uh server has had
this many requests
um and yeah these sort of info
information so
one request has failed 167
requests have been received and we can
see the server response time is 2.16
millisecond
which is quite decent for this use case
and yeah this sort of information
that you can you can see about your
service um and this is the way you can
build your machine learning models
deploy them and also monitor the machine
learning models
so yeah that in a nutshell was a demo a
quick demo maybe the last 10 minutes we
can take questions
all right perfect thank you for the demo
it was really interesting
yeah let's take a couple of other
questions so
uh honey is asking regarding continuous
journey
do you feel that online machine learning
algorithms that can be updated as raw
data comes without needing to
train from scratch should be preferred
to their type of algorithms
so i didn't get the question can you
repeat again
yeah so regarding the continuous
learning
do you feel that online machine learning
algorithms
that can be updated as the new data
comes without needing to retrain from
scratch
should be preferred to their type of
algorithms
good question yeah i think it can be
smart
to start from a pre-trade model use some
transfer learning capabilities
by not starting from scratch that is one
way to do
so machine learning operations also
enables transfer learning
and of course you can keep updating your
model periodically to implement
continued learning and
it keeps the model updated in that way
so
the the smarter you are the better you
better it is
uh if you're able to start from a model
which is already pre-trained
you're able to make it learn by using
transparent that is smart
so there's no one way to go about it
it's about solving your problem in the
most
optimal way yeah definitely
all right so yoha is asking
uh do you have any experience with using
challenger models
two models side by side where one is
used for production output
and the other is the challenger for
monitoring the quality
the e detecting gradual degradation
for the production model
yeah i have some experience uh working
with that
is there a question around that yeah
so what was your experience about that
yeah um it is quite useful um to assure
the quality
in real time to see how
the models are performing in the
production model and especially
we can validate using the challenger
model um
so that is one innovative to do
inference in production but yeah there
are other ways as well where we can a b
test and also every use case is
different
so yeah
yeah yeah that's it's good to be
use case agnostic yeah
yeah i like the idea of the challenger
it's seems interesting
i should i should read more about that
yeah all right so uh another one from
lowry
is asking how do you find the workforce
to implement
mls do you train data scientists to
understand devops
software developers to understand
machine learning or do you
train dedicated email ops engineers
um so i personally feel like it's good
to have dedicated people for
dedicated jobs and if you have data
scientists
who are good at developing models it's
good to keep it like that because
there's a lot to learn and the ecosystem
is evolving
so if one tries to be a generalist
that one might not be good at narrow
tasks
or there's there's a lot uh happening
and it's hard to keep up with
the changing world so it's it's good to
have data scientists dedicated to
develop cutting-edge models and then
machine learning engineers can of course
of course be updated with machine
learning ops because
it will be there for a long time and
it is evolving to serve the future
business needs and the current ones as
well
all right okay
all right yeah there is another question
from nissrin she is asking
how do we integrate i guess the email
ops platform
with the company's website
or the company's platform ah so
you can um easier way to do it is
by using a rest api based
ml service that you can develop using
machine learning ops
and then you can integrate your rest api
endpoint to your website
to serve the user needs and that way
you're able to
keep your machine learning operations
separate from
web development or the application
development for your company
and keeps it easy
yeah definitely yeah especially most of
those cloud providers they did they
prepare
end points that you can quickly consume
in a restful way yeah cool
uh another one from dennis is asking
about the demo
what are the triggers for training of
the weather
support vector machine model ah the
triggers for the pipeline
um yeah i can maybe share the screen
once again okay
so the triggers here are
of course changes in the code uh
so i've enabled that if i commit
something to the master branch for
example
it triggers the pipeline and then
for this demo i have kept if i train
model scaler i've enabled the pipeline
but this is not a good practice
don't enable the model scaler but rather
go for the model
if you train a model then enable the
pipeline
and it it depends from need to need
okay yeah i think
we don't have any other questions
actually we we started a poll
just to know all of the attendees to
know your backgrounds
so please vote if you are a data
scientist or a data engineer or
have an idea about that
i i have a last
thing to share with you all so
about the book i previously shared
so i've been working with a publisher to
get that out and
the publisher promised to send some of
us the free book
so there's a chance that some of you if
you're interested to learn
the book i can send you out for free so
there's a
free giveaway that we can make happen
and it would be for the first 15
people who reach out to me for the first
come first serve based
basis so i'll be able to send you a free
ebook in
10 to 15 days of time that
the only thing that that you might help
me with is give a review on amazon
because it helps
get the message out and to really know
how the book is
so feel free to reach out to me on
this email um if you're interested to
get a free ebook
sure
all right yeah yeah thank you for
for for the freebies it's always good to
have free stuff
definitely i love freebies as well
cool all right i think that's it we
don't have
any other questions in the chat section
i think we can
wrap it up yeah feel free if you have
any other or final words
yeah uh thanks first of all pi data and
the team for inviting me
it's a pleasure to be able to share this
idea
and it's quite amusing that still in
pandemic days we can come together
like this and share knowledge with each
other and
personally if you're a software engineer
data scientist or aspire to be a data
scientist
i encourage you to learn machine
learning ops because
this is the future of operationalizing
machine
machine learning on scale so this is
becoming industry standard day by day
and it can be quite rewarding for you
actually to learn
machine learning ops for your company
for your team
and to solve your business problems in
the most optimal way
and also i'm here as well feel free to
reach out
always like uh brainstorming on
different questions
so feel free to reach out to me on
linkedin
and i hope to be stay stay connected
with you all
and thank you very much for your time
thank you
all right yeah thank you emmanuel for
the presentation and demo
it was really interesting and thanks for
everyone who attended
this meetup and really looking forward
to see you in
next month meetups stay safe and
bye bye awesome bye bye
bye